Pittsburgh Penguin Riley Smith back by the
attacking net Pon snaps it down low off the
glove a quick neander a chance couldn't put it
home Maring then off the bar on the ltir for
the Rangers a turnover here Here Comes hroa
zahna finds lat Tang he'll rip it blub save
quick but he had a rebound we remember him well
here in Pittsburgh weeds his way through Center
on a one-year deal with the Rangers a shot there
handled by jar and oh frees it ok Conor up the
wall Pon takes it there swings it over to Carlson
gel in the slot Carlson again gensel shoots quick
the save and the rebound driven wide by Crosby
Pon across off the skate of Carlson Kel Crosby
off ired oh they're humming but they can't beat
quick just rolls off and then he takes a pass
from Carlon bang as Malin takes it back in his own
Edge from a ridiculous angle and good thing that
Tristan jar scrambled to get back in the stage
turnover here at Center by Graves here comes lford
near pass grav backhander scores and a turnover
capitalized by the Rangers it's one- nothing New
York it looked like the Penguins were just
fine but just a little hiccup by Graves and
that's how quick it happens zanana Jad
up to lefr and how about the mits going
forehand backhand shelfy up over the left
Club hand of Tristan jari and one nothing
Rangers passing back to the point kaco there
the forward down low for Schneider chips it
behind the net coie Schneider will let it rip
and a save by jari his pass deflects nearly
right to Crosby his Advantage at back in his own
end for trouba theang picked off by crder Zan at
Over The Line holding it shooting it good save
jari couple huge ones still New York in front
one nothing no change to that tonight the Tang of
shot that's blocked by wheeler Hain keeps it alive
nice move around Savanah looking in front Smith
couldn't get it to go the rebound kicked out by
quick well not from the well the penguin have had
their chances Riley Smith with a great chance and
there's the dexterity and the flexibility of
Jonathan Quick he never gives up on any play
with simple plays from skilled players you think
they could do it in their sleep and it's almost
like they're overthinking the process right now
and a stroza carries back in Centers Great save
quick Whack It Away zahna Jeff Carter and that
second unit trying to make something happen as
he dumps it in in estrosa had to hop on his
stick back for lat Tang he'll snap it down
low redirected a save by quick on zahora Quicks
lost his glove as a wrist shot goes in they store
hit stroza put it to the net and
the penguins have tied this game
and [Music] [Applause] [Music] won the referee
say play on play on but I've never seen a player
shoot at the player's bare hand and it go in
and Jonathan Quick saying I got no glove I
got no he actually tried to make the save it
might have hit his hand and it still went in
and Peter lavet losing his mind I kind of
get it but this is the way the NHL is now
it doesn't matter if you lose your gear
you got to get possession back before the
whistle comes holy moly this following the
coach's challenge the play is offside no
goal finish that thought
when when uh you challenge
quick Crosby over the line back to gel shot
save rebound how did that not go it bounced
behind quick but stayed out now everybody's
coming together here we go in behind Jonathan
Quick and boy was quick lucky there as he just
kicks it with his heel out of the blue paint
great opportunity early on oh man in this period
also with Lars Eller coming down the wing and
there's Jonathan Quick kicking out with his heal
there Jake [Music] kensel and just a simple shot
on goal drifting and then sending it back to the
point Eric Guston paner back to Guston he'll pass
to paner shot save jari had to work through some
traffic to make that stop and the pen clear now
this game is kind of Unwound here you feel like
the next goal is just huge as he's challenges
Panera taco BS it around for Jones down low he
finds pulie backhanding in front kako a couple
cracks couldn't get it to go and he's pile drive
to the ice by Graves today with the Penguins down
the goal save after save and keeps the rang always
an awesome atmosphere know he was playing against
the Rangers oh yeah 70 points in 71 career games
here comes Thro back in centering in front jar
a great save cross crease on lafier Kuba snuck
in from the back door and then the saucer pass
great anticipation by jar moving from his left to
Pon good work down low able to get it to Carlson
can't clear here's Miller with it Rangers Heming
the Penguins in their own zone right now as paner
and shot is kicked out jari a rebound stop on
trouba my goodness trist Tristan jari he needs
a little help Josh he's in there doing everything
he can Rangers have put the 27 shots on goal only
one's gotten past Tristan jari makes another save
there and another one on the rebound with Z banad
whacking away to push back here because this ice
is tilted in a bad way and if it's not for Tristan
jar this one's getting shade for gensel cross ice
leang rumbles back in Chris leang looking for a
lane down low for gensel the E game point streak
Crosby shot and a save made by quick but quickly
answers o Conor pushes it back down to the
ranger Zone off the face off TR right at top
his own grease turn over denel whacked
at that and quick able to stab it okay
gorki the pengin haven't done everything you
want them to do here in this game but at the
end of the day they're one shot away from
tying the score they're hanging around and
after back to the point O Conor collides with
Miller it's taken by Graves push to Center for
gel he's over the line across Crosby his shot
quick spectacular stop they just had a great
opportunity off the rush just an absolute gorgeous
saucer pass from Jake gensel to Sydney Crosby the
reverse onetime by Sid gets it off the stick quick
but it's incredible Eller twisting and turning
back to the point Pon dips around laier throws
it across nobody there was intended for Eller
other away paner loer air with him paner across
loer air jry saves the game with that save saucer
pass from the bread man to lafrenier and Tristan
jari gobbles it up back down low taken by latan
penguins have to be a little extra aggressive
here as aari is dumped to the ice here comes
nto shorthanded dropping it Pon to the net say
quick rebound it would not go for the Penguins the
crisscross between nto and Marcus Pon and Pon just
Powers his way into the goal and oh man Matt NE
with an unbelievable chance here to chip it on the
backand Keandre Miller right there with the glove
Crosby slaps it ahead hoping for gel he's ahead
of the pack as jar Sprints to the bench extra
skater on 17 seconds to go it's Malin to Crosby
shooting shoulder save by quick and out of Play It
Goes what a Hustle by Jake gensel to get to the
loose Puck get it to aghy Malin and then whip
it over to Sydney Crosby just a little hesitation
by Sid to dust it off one time and oh my goodness
it's out the center three seconds down it goes
that's the game and the New York Rangers spoil
the party here PPG paint Serena Jonathan Quick
with his second shut out of the season the 60th